whenever i bring up ernest becker's work
which i do
and yours quite a bit
i find it surprising
how that it's not a lot more popular
in a sense that uh no not well i don't
mean just
your book yeah uh that's well written
people should read it should buy it
whatever
uh i think it has the same kind of
qualities
that are useful to think about as like
jordan peterson's work and
stuff like that but i i just mean like
why people uh
are not don't think of that as a
compelling
description of um the core
of the human condition like i think what
you mentioned about heidegger's
quite connects with me quite well so i
ask
on this podcast i often ask people if
they're afraid of death
that's like almost every single part i
almost always get criticized for asking
world-class people scientists and
technologists and about fear of death
and
the meaning of life and on the fear of
death
they often like
don't say anything interesting what i
mean by that
is they haven't thought deeply about it
like what
you kind of brought this up a few times
of really letting it sink
in they kind of say this thing about
what exactly you said which is like
uh it's something that happens not today
like i'm aware that it's something that
happens yeah and i'm not
the thing they usually say is i'm not
afraid of death
i just want to live a good life kind of
thing
yeah and what i'm trying to express is
like when i
look in their eyes and the kind of the
the core of the conversation
it looks like they haven't really become
like they haven't really meditated on
death i guess the question is um
what do i say to people that
there's something to really think about
here like
there's some demons some realities that
need to be faced
yeah by more people well that's a tough
one
you know i could tell you what not to do
you know so when we are young and
annoying
yeah um a lot of famous people
mostly psychologists because that's who
we intersected with
that you know we would lay out these
ideas
and they would be well i i don't think
about death like that
so these ideas must be wrong and we
would say
well you don't think about death because
you're lucky enough to be comfortably
ensconced in a cultural world view from
which you derive self-esteem
and that has it's spared you the
existential excruciations that would
otherwise arise
but that's like freud you know you're
repressing so you either agree with me
in which case
i'm right or you disagree with me
in which case you're repressing and i'm
right well so that that's the
the the nietzsche thing i what i've felt
when i've
there'd been a moment in my life moments
in my life when i really thought about
death i mean there's not too many like
really really thought about it and feel
the thing when you felt that eight maybe
i'm traumatizing or romanticizing it but
uh
i feel like it's uh uh the conservatives
call it
popular like or the movie matrix call it
the
red pill yeah moment uh i feel like it's
a dangerous
thought because um i feel like i'm
taking a step out of society like
there's a nice narrative that we've all
constructed you are and i'm
taking a step out and uh
it feels there's this feeling like
you're basically
droughting i mean it's not a good
feeling
it is not but this gets back to the
heidegger kierkegaard school of anxiety
you are
stepping out yeah and you are
momentarily shrugging off
the the again the culturally constructed
psychological accoutrements that allow
you
to stand up in the morning and
so i i mean if that in that sense it
feels like
i mean uh what do you uh
how do you have that conversation
because i guess i i i'm
dancing around a set of questions which
is like
i guess i'm disappointed that people
don't
are not uh as willing to step outside
like uh even just uh even any kind of
thought experiment
yeah let's forget uh denial death like
um
there's there's not a community of
people let's to take an easy one that i
think is scientifically ridiculous
which is there's a community of people
that believe that
uh the earth is flat yeah uh or actually
even even better
the space is fake yeah uh like what i
find
surprising is that a lot of people i
talk to
are not willing to uh
be like imagine if it is like imagine
the earth is flat like think about it
right a lot of people just like no the
earth is round
they they're like uh like scientists
yeah too they're like yes
well actually wait have you actually
like thought about it like
imagine like a thought experiment
that like basically step outside the
little narrative that we
are comfortable with now that one in
particular
is has a really strong
uh evidence uh and scientific validation
so on it's pretty simple thing to show
that it at least is not flat uh but
just the willingness to take a step
outside of the stories that bring us
comfort
it's uh been disappointing that people
are not willing to do that
yeah and i think uh the philosophy that
you've constructed
and that ernest beck is constructed and
you've tested i think is really
compelling and the fact that people
aren't
often willing to take that step yeah
disappointing
well yes but perhaps understandable i
mean one of
this is an anecdote of course but when
we were trying to
get a publisher for our book um
i had him we had a meeting with um
a publisher who uh
published some malcolm gladwell books
yeah
and she said i'm very interested in your
book but
can you write it without mentioning
death because people don't like death
and we're like now it's really kind of
central
um and i think that's part of it
i think again if these ideas
have merit and i actually like the way
that you put it lex it's that
to step away is to momentarily
expose yourself to all of
the anxiety yeah
that our identity and our beliefs
typically enable us to manage i think
it's as simple as that
yeah i i had this experience um
in college with my best friend uh
who got really high uh uh
and he forgot it was uh in the winter it
was really freezing
it was memorable to me i think it's an
analogy it's very useful
um so he went to get some pizza
and of course and
uh he so i and he left
me outside and said i'll be back in five
minutes
and he forgot that he left me outside
and i remember it was
i was in like shorts yeah it was
freezing winter
wow and i remember standing outside it's
a dorm
and i'm looking from the outside in it's
a light and it's warm
and i'm just standing there frozen i
think for an hour or more
and i that's how i think about it like i
just i don't give a damn about the
stupid
winter i just want to i'd like it's like
a i'm drawn to be back to the warm
yeah and that's how i feel about
thinking about like death it's like
yeah at a certain point it's like
it's too much it's like that cold i like
i want to be back into the warmth
you know getting back to heidegger for a
moment i i like
the yeah he uses a lot
the idea of feeling at home
not as like in your house but just
feeling like you're comfortably situated
you